die reduzierung komplexer politischer
sachverhalte auf ein einziges thema in
der regel bezogen aber der minderheit im
land ist ein tradiertes mitte des
faschismus
was haben wir heute erneut haben wir
heute erneut
ich habe heute erneut vorgeführt bekommt
die migranten sind an allem schuld
eine ähnliche aktion hatte sie diese
pause schon einmal gegeben und ich finde
es ist zeit dass die demokraten in
diesem lande sich gegen diese art der
rhetorischen aufrüstung die am ende zu
einer enthemmung führt deren resultat
gewalttaten auf den straßen ist es ist
zeit dass die demokratie sie gegen diese
leute wert herr präsident
präsident die zwischen die frage die ich
stellen wollte bezog sich aber eine
äußerung des herrn bauland das zeigen
des hitlergrußes sei unappetitlich
das zeigen des hitlergrußes eine
straftat die strafrechtlich verfolgt
werden muss
ja die art der rede die wir hier gehört
haben noch einmal die eindimensionalität
komplexer strukturen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert die
reduzierung auf ein einziges thema das
ist ein stilmittel das bekannt ist
das wird kombiniert der präsident bin
sofort fertig es wird kombiniert mit
aussagen wie das tausendjährige reich
sei ein vogel schiffs bauland die menge
vogelschutz ist ein misthaufen und auf
den gehören sie in der deutschen
geschichte
[Applaus]
[Musik]